you said a quote to me that stuck and I
tell everyone this basically you know
got on to the business on the outside of
here yeah and you were like man not a
business if I can't function without ya
yes and I was like a true business
person can also function in a business a
good a good anyone in business will
always replace themself yes because most
people that are working as a member of
staff with it as an employee or whatever
they're scared to replace himself
because then they've made themself we've
done done but actually if you place
yourself then you make yourself promoted
yes see this is big when you said that
because it's like I think I remember
saying now I know I'm repeatable no one
comes in London you're like uh-huh be
replaceable a limb from your busy was
actually and it's a boat Lake it's not
about the way you doing it's about just
doing everything you can to make things
grow well no no in a good business
decision being able to replace yourself
system on our teams in place and work
out the return on investment make profit
make money sell use all this with me the
business yeah and you can literally
apply it yeah but I think like how you
lead by example is what people might see
as problem there's not a problem those
problems don't exist
it's just lets make solutions yeah so
it's just like when you see you give
examples of like I can't do this can't
do that it's not cons it's like can you
do yeah how are we gonna do it let's do
it yeah and yeah it's just how can i
yeah I always say average people avoid
problems poor people find problems and
which people solve them what can you do
to get past that bien to make that big
step because I think that will holds
lots of people by especially when they
think it comes out like a big cost or
since it seems big what you do to get
over the fear you get to the next step I
think maybe be scared of something else
like not doing it
oh yeah so name of the day live short
and we're gonna be dead we're gonna be
get
in a hundred years no one that's
currently on this planet will be on the
planet
definitely 150 are gonna court with a
cure for life there will be yes 6012
property you could maybe but you can't
Bank on it okay - and even tomorrow so I
just think instead of saying I'm scared
to do this because it's gonna be a big
investment or because he won't go wrong
how's about saying what if I don't walk
your home then what are the consequences
of not doing it yeah you know and also
positive peer pressure if you're
surrounded by people that above you
I know you can bring you down and saying
it can't be done you can't do that you
can't live it you know then that's gonna
make it really hard for you to step out
ways for me hang out on people like you
and the team and everyone's a can-do
person everyone's making decisions
making money
life is short like if you're not around
people they were looking at the bigger
picture you're actually doing yourself a
disservice yeah so I think you need to
be able to identify straight away it's
this good people to be around are these
good people to be around we'll only let
people in on the team I've got the right
energy because of energy and attitude is
better than skill mm-hmm I mean if you
got both then it's really cool yeah I
think as well like I think it comes back
to the fear thing again if you've got
close bonds with people but they're
actually you know good for ya or the
holding you back or there's more minds
that takes both stupid like I don't
and I think you need to be brave if you
want big things because it comes at the
cost you know and it's like you've gotta
grow yourself I think I think when
people try and hold you back and of
course man we come across this all the
time that we if we become to the crash
course and then they've got most people
that come to the crash course have been
told at least by one person not to be
there mmm-hmm and then they're there and
they're like man I'm grounded in the
ocean but it's other people that are
trying to protect them or it's people
that are just jealous because when you
step out and start kicking ass in life
you just remind those old friends and
when they could have been
[Music]